[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient par
les sports le troisième numéro de cette
saison sur tb 78 l'émission et quand
encore et toujours consacré à
l'actualité sportive locale et nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous pour
décortiquer et analyser à cette
actualité
vu les conditions à sanitaire certains
sont en plateau et d'autres via écran
interposé à présentation on commence à
ma droite c'est notre spécialiste
cyclisme ici connaît également
énormément dans tous les sports il a
notamment fait du roller à haut niveau
il vient de commencer
le volley ball le capitaine ilya
dujarrier est avec nous dans cette
éviction
selon michael bonjour yann nouvelle
passion du coup pour le volley-ball pas
si pluie passion et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est parti tout simplement parce que
c'est vrai que après le titre de
champion du monde un peu de difficulté
le confinement était a été préjudiciable
pour moi est là depuis depuis septembre
depuis septembre j'ai commencé le volley
est en effet j'ai une grosse envie de
progresser
voilà les moulins par contre aujourd'hui
désolé les eaux n'ont pas les parallèles
et on y fera passer l'autre côté musique
lui aussi savait qu'on en plateau si sa
troisième apparition à cette émission et
les journalistes chez tv 60,18 il est
passionné de football italien c'est une
encyclopédie vivante sur le sport et le
sport yvelinois il a sa rubrique dans
cette émission à chaque enregistrement
l'italienne lover diego et canale est
avec nous bonjour michael comment allez
vous ça va très bien content de
retrouver la team encore une fois pour
une 3è émission d'autant que l'actualité
n'est pas forcément bonne en ce moment
donc le sop sport c'est un peu ma petite
bulle d'oxygène du monde alors on va
respirer tous ensemble à cette actualité
morose
nous serons donc 3 en plateau les autres
sont avec nous via écran interposé je le
disais précédemment un musique ce grand
fan des verts de saint-etienne est
également
l'état le chroniqueur sport ils adorent
leurs valets le basket
légalement il va se donner à fond comme
d'habitude stéphane de bizet et son
nounours ils sont avec nous dans cette
émission
c'était fin des mises et comment allez
vous eh bien j'ai changé de club
maintenant je supporte le milan ac j'en
ai marre des verts d'accord on est
obligé de coups de changer votre musique
de présentation alors oui oui non mais
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre des
supporter c'est le message est passé
en tout cas c'est juste pour embêter
grégory van persie gesture à un gorille
ans on le précise alors lui aussi
connecté via un écran interposé musique
il est désormais vide les genres de
cette émission c'est simple s'il ne peut
pas venir on annule tout de suite les
missions vous allez passer un bon moment
avec lui à j'en suis à persuader le
gladiateur pierre chevallier est avec
nous pierre quand allez-vous 1 8 k salut
grec sylviane salut à tous saluons bien
du rugby-club de versailles angelots
précise exact forme et bonheur à tous
donc on a des gens si vous n'êtes pas la
prochaine émission
ben j'ai appris ça je sais c'est trop
d'honneur c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
agréable à noter que j'essayerai de
faire un effort pour être toujours là
mais les fans alors on garde le meilleur
pour la fin musique
il est l'un des chouchous du public
hibino elle reçoit énormément de lettres
de fans
il avait reçu des demandes de mariage
sur les réseaux sociaux la légende le
mythe genlis ancien coach de plaisir est
avec nous coach comment allez vous
bonjour à tous mais moi ça va tout pour
moi toujours je suis pour perdurer cette
idée devienne un football mais quand
j'ai repris la place de stéphane
ils sont continues tu es tu es bienvenue
jean et les demandes en mariage sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est une légende ou pas
et ouais mais bon
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission prend maintenant la direction
de conflans l'équipe locale qui évolue
en r1 vient d'éliminer aux tirs au but
aulnésienne une équipe de la même
division pourtant rien n'a été simple
dans ce 5e tour de coupe de france
malmené les ennemis noix sont menés 2-1
pendant une grosse partie du match par
les joueurs de seine saint denis
mais ils reviennent dans le match grâce
à un penalty généreux avant de
l'emporter 3 aux tirs au but avec cette
victoire conflent et le dernier
représentant des yvelines encore en
course dans cette coupe de france 2020
2021 est forcément l'équipe veut aller
le plus loin possible au stade de france
ce serait bien je présente le plus loin
possible c'est c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau voilà on continue on fait notre
petit bonhomme de chemin on travaille on
est content d'être ensemble
pierre chevallier je vous ai vu faire
une petite grimace
le stade de france c'est pas possible
c'est ça me paraît ambitieux on s'était
déjà un petit peu ou belges et dans
cette émission et est incertaine
italienne lover c'était déjà pas mal
positionné sur le sur le trajet de nos
club yvelinois
bon là là quand on regarde un petit peu
en arrière ça fait quand même pas mal de
monde
pas mal de monde sur le carreau on va on
va leur souhaiter le meilleur maintenant
tous tous derrière eux mais le stade de
france je pense que
d'autres équipes amateurs et petit
poucet se sont qu'à s'y sont cassé les
dents il y en a pas beaucoup qui ont
réussi après on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
surprise dans cette dans cette année si
particulier alors je le précise un jedi
canada avait pour ambition d'avoir
peut-être un club yvelinois le plus loin
possible dans cette compétition c'était
ma première envolée disons que je
voulais voir un petit poucet vinuales
est loin dans cette coupe de france à
l'époque où j'avais fait cette chronique
je crois qu'il y en avait encore 8 à 0
chronique de l'année
c'était la première il y en avait encore
huit en lice des clubs yvelinois et il
en reste plus qu'un donc je vais
m'abstenir de faire des pronostics sur
les prochains tours sur la prochaine
rencontre mais en tout cas non moi ce
que je voulais dire c'est que font
d'ailleurs vite rien le 1er novembre sur
scène qui évolue au même niveau
rires moi ce que je voulais dire c'est
oui à conflans on sait que voilà
l'actualité du week-end n'avait pas été
bonnes donc de terminer sur ce petit
sourire ce week-end à conflans sainte
honorine les joueurs qui ont d'ailleurs
fini 9e minute dommages à samuel patil
enseignants qui a été assassiné je
trouvais que ça se terminait bien trop
pour le week-end c'était le petit
sourire pour terminer le week-end
jarrier qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cette victoire aux tirs au but de
conflent on s'en fout on s'en fout de la
manière de trouver au gagner ce qui
compte c'est de gagner c'est tout peu
importe le résultat importe la manière
seul le résultat compte
admettons qu'ils passent de 3 tours de
plus ce que je leur souhaite
et bien la victoire oui ce sera
historique pour pour pour eux et ce
serait très très bien mais la victoire
au penalty face à aulnay en
on on s'emm n'aura plus aucun souvenir
donc l'important c'est passé c'est le
passé
chaque tour et même parfois si si c'est
sur une erreur d'arbitrage ou si c'est
sur un coup du sort
parce qu'un athlète parce que
l'adversaire à crever ou qu aux caisses
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça et la
victoire la victoire
alors elle en est moins belle bien sûr
mais elle mais toujours honorable genre
ce qui est intéressant également c'est
que cette équipe de conflans éliminé
l'équipe qui les avait éliminés l'année
précédente au troisième tour une hygiène
une belle revanche
et oui oui tout à fait bon après il
paraît que la photo de greg est
placardée à tous les clubs démunis des
prothèses démises abri mais bon sinon
c'est qu'ils nomment quand une chaise de
passer parce que ils ont pas encore
rencontré le monde entre guillemets de
gros morceaux
donc pourquoi pas un bon petit jeu
permettent encore de rêver sur au moins
au moins au moins un tour de plus après
on verra
mais là c'est vrai que pour l'instant
tout tout et tout est possible
sportivement il n'y a rien comme
problème s'était fait des bises et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que comme disait yann on s'en
fout de la façon dont ils sont passés
après c'était premier conclu quatrième
donc le passage est logique mais le tour
suivant il pour affronter affronter
pardon vitry qui est leader aussi de son
championnat et qui est une grosse
puissance au niveau défensif
le véritable test que je pense ce sera
le tour suivant donc vous êtes plutôt
confiant sur cette rencontre
quand même non non non je pense que je
pense qu'ils passeront pas le tour
suivant
sans vouloir porter la poisse et gorica
les votre pronostic bien non je
m'abstiendrai encore une fois de
pronostic mais ce qui peut être
intéressant à souligner si que s'ils
franchissent ce sixième tour au 7e tour
il ya potentiellement une équipe a joué
dans les dom-tom donc ça peut être aussi
une belle histoire de partir avec ce
groupe de vivre une aventure dans l'est
dans les dom tom en tout cas à partir de
ce 7e tour il ya cette possibilité là
qui est offerte à quelques clubs qui
sont à ce 7e tour ou de recevoir
également l'équipe d'édouard aux 60
possède également alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons pas oui ni
cannabis et je crois normalement les
clubs de ligue 2 devrait arriver au 7e
tour mais que ça a été repoussé d'un
tour j'ai parce que michael e s'il a des
infos là dessus alors je n'ai pas
d'infos là dessus mais je crois
qu'effectivement c'est les seuls car
c'est ça effectivement les clubs de
ligue 2 ligue 1 on a repoussé leur
entrée en lice en coupe de france en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à
partir du sixième tour sont les clubs de
national il y avait déjà des clubs de
nationale 2 qui étaient en lice à partir
du sixième tome est aussi des clubs de
national donc la troisième division
française au niveau du football qui qui
ont entreront en lice dans cette coupe
de france
alors nous allons maintenant maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de golf
un stade de golf et inaugure au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
14 octobre dernier
il servira notamment aux futures pépites
coup de projecteur également sur les
finances dans le monde du sport ça sera
à votre envolé à grégory mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va parler du
couvre-feu dans les yvelines le monde du
sport ivy noah est bousculé par le
couvre feu annoncé par emmanuel macron
certains matchs de basketball ou de
handball est programmé en soirée sont
d'ores et déjà annulés dans le
département pendant plusieurs semaines
au club de football de poissy lille
devrait pas y avoir de conséquences sur
les matches à domicile de l'équipe
seniors les rencontres de national de
son programme est généralement en fin de
journée mais ce sont les rencontres à
l'extérieur en bretagne qui interroge
les dirigeants le match se déroule à 18
heures donc à 20h45 ce qu'il faut une
heure de battement nous partons avec nos
équipes devront nous restait
effectivement sur la bretagne les frais
nécessaires et supplémentaires dont ce
sera difficile à supporter
compte tenu notre budget rester sur
place 20 personnes sur un hôtel
effectivement ce n'est pas envisageable
pour nous néanmoins si nous rentrons
j'espère vraiment nous aurons des
dérogations liane qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
bah oui c'est ce que je pense enfin moi
c'est ce que je pense aussi
vous partez d'un endroit où il ya un
confinement
moi je suis parti en week-end le parti
ce week-end à reims je me dis souvent
l'habitude de rentrer tard quand je
rentre de week end entrée vers minuit 1h
du matin je me dis tiens je pars de
reims il est 20 heures
je dois aller vivre enfin je vis en
normandie
donc je dois traverser l'île de france
comment est ce que je fais au volant de
ma voiture donc je ne peut contaminer
personnes mais comment est ce que je
fais en traversant l'île de france aux
heures où en effet on est en plein on
est en plein et pas de couvre feu en
plein couvre-feu voilà donc
donc c'est vrai que là c'est quand même
d'aider des questions qu'il faut qu'il
faut se poser est est donc voilà c'est
vrai que quelqu'un qui a un déplacement
à faire qui part de bretagne à 21h et
qui va rentrer chez lui à ben oui bien
sûr en plus bon pour une activité
sportive et vous savez comment je peux
défendre quelques activités sportives
qu'elle soit et que ce soit du niveau
professionnel où que ce soit au niveau
amateur
voilà j'ai énormément la comprendre que
l'on que l'on nous interdisent d'aller
d'aller faire du sport au début vous
pendant pendant tout depuis depuis qu'on
allait rencontrer cette maladie on
entend que si on est sportif on est on
se défend mieux face à cette maladie que
healy a très peu de cas contacts dans
les salles de sport ou aux caisses et
bien là confinement et on ferme tout et
on nous interdit même en deux
patrouilles match pas tous les matches
permet pas de match là je parle
d'entraînement entraînement amateur
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez plus faire de
sport en groupe
donc là aujourd'hui c'est reprise de la
course à pied et reprise du boulot pour
tout le monde au rugby par exemple on
peut quand même continuer à jouer à
pierre chevalier
oui c'est ça c'est c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué sur votre antenne un peu plus
tôt dans la semaine on a on a des
aménagements des aménagements à
respecter et qui conditionne est
clairement la pratique la pratique du
rugby pour le sporting qui nous
intéresse à la fois sur les
entraînements et sur les matchs puisque
justin jusqu'à maintenant et jusqu'à
nouvel ordre les donc les entraînements
sont permis ils ont simplement dû être
avancée avancer compte tenu du couvre
feu donc à 19h pour la plupart 18h30
pour ceux qui peuvent notamment pour les
jeunes et on a encore le droit
pour l'instant je touche du bois on a
encore le droit de prendre des douches
et donc d'utiliser les vestiaires je
crois que d'une manière générale ce qui
est ce qui est difficile à lire
c'est la cohérence la cohérence de
toutes ces mesures et de tout c'est de
toutes ces consignes on est je trouve
dans les ports amateur et en france
d'une manière générale assez discipliné
c'est à dire que toute façon on applique
les mesures barrières
il est parfois difficile de lire de lire
de dire le la cohérence de ces mesures
parce que vous prenez le match de rugby
par exemple on passe 80 minutes les uns
sur les autres en contact là vraiment je
reprends sono exprès à venir au contact
et à se plaquer à gagner à jouer à
avancer un match de rugby et on n'aurait
pas le droit derrière de prendre une
douche à 15 avec hésitation
distanciation sociale ça c'est un petit
peu difficile à dire mais en attendant
on s'y fait et on fait avec les mesures
combien on va écouter justement bamba
c'est qu'ils jouent à l'entente le
chesnay-versailles au basket par contre
ils ne peuvent plus s'entraîner
actuellement en écoute on peut plus
s'entraîner donc le coach est en train
de voir des solutions
des courses des cordes et aller
s'entraîner à l'extérieur faire beaucoup
de courses et donc après c'est pas ça
qui va nous remettre dedans numéro on
espère compte d'ici là il y aura des
changements gens voulaient intervenir
peut-être oui oui je voulais rajouter
parce que ce que disait pierre c'était
encore pire que ça parce que d'une
municipalité à l'autre les décisions ce
ne sont pas les mêmes
donc pour reprendre encore le
championnat rugby ben je vous vous allez
faire un match à l'extérieur où tout se
passe normalement on a on a des
vestiaires on prend des douches
bon il n'y a pas de réception ça aussi
le bon comme le disait pierre on le fait
mal aujourd'hui pendant 80 minutes à se
rentrer dedans et après on peut pas on
peu pas beaucoup à côté modération bien
sûr
voilà comment avec modération bien sûr
laure dumergues et du perrier du banga
linux 6 non mais par contre donc ce sera
un week-end comme ça et par exemple nous
à gif sur yvette
ben non autorisé les matchs de rugby
mais il n'y a pas de vestiaire il n'y a
pas de douche ce qu'imaginer un petit
peu avec la période actuelle dans
laquelle l'enfant né faire un match de
rugby des gens qui se déplace en bus
vient de faire un match de rugby et
derrière ils ont pas de douche
ils ont pas de vestiaires donc gros
montée nazem bus avec aliou faye match
non mais au niveau sanitaire
excusez moi mais et c'est quand même pas
mal non plus gros c'est un petit peu
n'importe quoi on risque de cornas virus
ne se transmet la grippe l'on se
transmet les rues mais l'homme est
certes via ce phénomène mais mais y'a
aucune aucune
aucune articulation aucune harmonisation
autour autour de ces décisions
grégory vous voulez intervenir juste
pour dire je suis à peu près d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit sur la cohérence
des mesures aussi la difficulté à
appliquer on s'est adapté le sport
amateur s'est teint mat et qu'on adapte
et continue de s'adapter mais c'est
forcément difficile moi je parle de
l'exemple du football dans mon club de
jouy en josas voilà pour pas leur faire
de la pub
on a pris la décision ça fait très
longtemps on a été éliminés dès le tour
de cadrage était même pas le premier
tour c'est le tour de cadrage
c'est le ton juste avant juste pour dire
c'est ça et juste pour dire que voilà on
s'est adapté on a pris la décision
pendant les vacances de la toussaint
d'avancé les entraînements de 18h à 20h
vous imaginez bien vous connaissez nos
horaires michael que aller s'entraîner à
18 heures c'est très difficile donc pour
nourrir un peu d'incertitude sur la
suite de la saison est ce qu'on va
pouvoir arriver totalement préparés on
n'est pas des professionnels donc on n'a
pas non plus une forme physique optimale
est ce qu'on va pouvoir arriver préparer
pour les matchs du dimanche qui se joue
à 15 heures donc ça y'a pas de soucis
pour les jouets mais beaucoup de
beaucoup d'inquiétude beaucoup de mal et
mathilde nationale 2 1 je le disais 18
heures c'est un peu devant la présidence
qui est ce qu'il a dit c'est nationale 2
ont pas forcément des budgets de clubs
professionnels donc à les payer un hôtel
aux joueurs sur un territoire quand on
va se déplacer c'est pas forcément
facile quand c'est ce que me disait le
président notamment
il leur demande et demande à ses joueurs
de prendre un sandwich le midi quand ils
font le déplacement en bretagne par
exemple donc payer un hôtel c'est un peu
compliqué si une demande déjà de savoir
sandwich on n'imagine pas pour les
chambres d'hôtel voilà c'est un peu
c'est un peu compliqué stéphane des
bises et alors vous vous êtes vous
faites durant deux fauteuils
vous faites également du basket fauteuil
ça se passe comment chez vous bah je
joue avec le chesnay-versailles au
basket c'est tout simplement annulé
pendant les quatre semaines voire les
deux qui vont suivre je pense on aura
pas d'entraînement pareil pour le hand
fauteuil
donc là c'est complètement à l'arrêt
mais c'est plus compliqué pour les
gymnases 1 pour l'instant la
problématique mais on n'a pas les on n'a
pas les locaux pour faire nos
entraînements en général c'est le soir
on lui enlevait de 20 heures
1h30 le basket c'est de 27 heures et
demie jusqu'à 8h15 mais pour revenir de
versailles c'est très juste pour être à
21h ici donc ils ont préféré annuler
tout simplement est-ce que c'est
fatigant peut-être pierre chevalier
emotionnellement peut-être également de
se dire c'est ya un entraînement qu
annuler l'entraînement qui est déplacé
on a plus de rythme en fait finalement
dans une semaine c'est plus une question
d'incertitudes parce que c'est pas ça ne
joue pas sur le moral c'est à dire que
jusqu'à maintenant les équipes qui les
équipes qui peuvent jouer parce qu'on
perd pas la notion de plaisir finalement
on perd on perd l'après match ça au
rugby qu'on connaît bien jean et moi
c'est effectivement on perd un peu de
sel on faire beaucoup de celles
d'ailleurs en août c'est qu'il ne fait
que jouer au rugby il n'y a pas de venir
à 3 mi-temps avec modération toujours
bien sûr voilà donc plein de ce côté là
on perd on perd la conviviale perdre on
perd une uniforme une forme de ce fait
le succès du rugby après je crois que je
crois qu'il faut malgré tout qu'on
mesure notre chance de pouvoir jouer
certaines équipes sont moins bien lotis
que nous avec justement pas de vestiaire
comme l'a rappelé jean d'autres sports
sont encore moins bien lotis que nous
pour tous les sports qui sont en
intérieur voulant que vous le rappelle
vous le rappeliez la différence et pour
tous les sports de gymnase volley basket
honda etc
dès qu'il y a des qui est une pratique à
l'intérieur il ya une concentration soit
disant plus forte et donc seuls les
sports de plein air peuvent continuer le
golf le rugby le foot le hockey sur
gazon j'en passe et des meilleurs et je
crois qu'il est je crois que de toute
façon dans cette période extrêmement
particulière il faut il faut se
raccrocher à ce qu'on a et est ce qu'on
peut faire encore pour l'instant on peut
encore jouer au rugby on peut encore
jouer au foot et à des conditions
contraignantes
on y perdent la convivialité mais pour
l'instant les deux saisons peuvent se
tenir en espérant qu'elle puisse se
termine moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
on rigole sur la troisième mi temps mais
moi je pense qu'elle a vraiment une
place primordiale dans certains clubs
ont dit que le sport a souvent une
vocation sociale les clubs de sport
c'est aussi une deuxième famille pour
beaucoup retirez voilà cette troisième
mi temps c'est aussi un petit peu
compliqué en plus de la pratique
sportive qui est de plus en plus
compliqué aussi
et j'ajoute aussi que pour les pour les
clubs sportifs locaux c'est aussi une
source de revenus non négligeable et
petite buvette ça peut aussi voilà
remplir remplir la caisse pour pour la
saison pour aider aussi les clubs qui
n'ont pas forcément des gros budgets
donc il ya plusieurs questions qui se
posent plusieurs incertitudes à cause de
voilà de toutes ces règles
gouvernementales
il est d'accord sûr que je suis d'accord
moi je
j'ai beaucoup bougé je suis venu à son
os ce soit aujourd'hui avec avec ce seul
discours c'est ça c'est je suis je suis
je suis désolé mais on doit nous laisser
le droit de pouvoir faire du sport
on va avoir le droit d'aller travailler
et donc de pouvoir côtoyer des gens avec
des règles sanitaires
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'à partir du
moment où le travail est fini on n'a
plus droit de pouvoir de pouvoir faire
bus dû faire du sport qui en plus je
vais encore de l'unam arguments nous
rend plus fort face à ce face à ce virus
donc
donc oui c'est vraiment enfin pour moi
c'est difficile assez difficile à
entendre voilà c'est le mot le mot pour
moi ça c'était difficile à entendre de
la terrasse comme ça les difficiles on
parle du monde du sport c'est le sujet
qui nous intéresse aussi mais pour les
restaurateurs et le monde de la culture
tout le monde doit doit s'adapter c'est
vraiment plusieurs secteurs qui sont
mises à mal par ces nouvelles mesures
oui il ya une urgence sanitaire après ça
met beaucoup de secteurs quand même en
danger
dernière question sur cette thématique
est ce que les championnats sont
finalement un petit peu faussée moi je
conseille à tous les clubs de prendre un
très très bon départ dans le championnat
parce que ceux qui déjà tous les points
qui se remplit ne seront plus à prendre
et en effet quand même pas commencé
certains donc pas encore commencé donc
justement des fêtes en fait un très très
bon départ parce que si si ça vient à ne
pas être finalisée peut-être que vous
aurez une bonne surprise à l'arrivée
parce que vous aurez bien gérer les
quelques matches que vous aurez pu jouer
et qui voudront avoir une grosse
importance
début de cette saison comme en septembre
quand on a abordé ce sujet là c'est
surtout un problème de calendrier
il ya de toute façon ça va être faussés
un moment ou un autre c'est quand tous
les matchs reportés ne pourront pas se
jouer là actuellement ce qui est
difficile à comprendre aussi dans le
calendrier du rugby par exemple en
fédérale c'est que les premiers matches
reportés de la première ou la deuxième
journée ont été reportés à février 2021
alors qu'il y avait une date de libre
pendant le calendrier international là
se le passe au dimanche le dimanche
d'après donc le dernier dimanche
d'octobre et le 1er novembre il y avait
cette possibilité de jouer en fait non
les matches ont automatiquement reporté
à février 2021 et plus les plus divers y
avoir deux matches reportés comme ça va
être a priori loca moins il y aura de
place dans le calendrier et là
effectivement il aura fallu prendre un
joli un bon départ parce que ça risque
d'être est figé comme ça et certains
matches joués ou jouets ont traité en
péréquation gens vous êtes d'accord on
est en l1 certains ont fait au quotidien
quoi il faut gagner les matches
dès à présent oui il capte un lâchage de
pouvoir les jouer et oui tout à fait il
faut essayer d'agréger parce que tout le
monde n'a pas la charge aujourd'hui le
pouvoir de pouvoir disputer ses matchs
donc il faut en profiter
stéphane brizé
mais c'est le championnat s'était arrêté
à la 3e journée saint-etienne était
champion de france thomas dernière
envolée une telle physique war que le
coc vidal être le grand vainqueur de la
saison
alors on continue cette page coup de
projecteur en parler des jo de 2024
plusieurs commune yvelinoise ont été
retenu comme centre 2 préparation pour
les jeux parisien grégory
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus tout à fait elles sont
seize 16 collectivités yvelinoise avoir
été choisi comme centre de préparation
pour les jeux olympiques et les jeux
paralympiques de 2024 une distinction
accordée par le comité d'organisation
avec le label terre de jeux 2024 alors
il ya des disciplines dans les
vinon est concerné par le beach volley
l'équitation le badminton le cyclisme
sur route le trampoline notamment les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
accueilleront par exemple les athlètes
du judo à guyancourt de la gymnastique
artistique a traduit handball à plaisir
on encore du bmx pour la course aux
clayes sous bois dans le concret un ces
centres de préparation serviront de lieu
de stage pour les sportifs de base
arrière aussi pendant la durée de la
compétition en théorie les athlètes
pourront y venir dès la fin des jeux
olympiques programmés en 2021 et ce
jusqu'en 2024
quand ils veulent quand ils veulent sur
le papier alors ma question sur le
papier après skis pour saisir cette
opportunité en tout cas dans les
derniers mois précédant les jo c'est sûr
que ces centres seront utilisés la
question sur cette thématique les jo de
2024 ont-ils déjà commencé avec cette
annonce
oui ou non
enfin petit duel entre vous pierre les
mets un petit peu de temps je vous
mettrais prochaine fois sur un duel
pierre et eliane pierre vous pensez gros
bruit ça commence et c'est
particulièrement dans ces périodes où on
parle de sport un petit peu un petit peu
tronquée des périodes sportive des
périodes sportif bouleversé par par ce
virus et des organes de l'organisation
vient de parler je pense que oui il faut
se raccrocher à il faut se raccrocher à
ces grands événements qui arrivent et
elle est à bien les préparer évidemment
il y aura toujours une épée de damoclès
est une grosse parenthèse sur la sur la
manière dont la saison 2021
c'est terminé 2020 2021 mais là à
l'horizon 2023 pour la coupe du monde de
rugby et 2024 pour les jo
en france il est pas il n'est pas anodin
il n'est pas il n'est pas inutile de se
projeter déjà est donc là de poser quand
même de poser les bases de des grands
travaux d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya ça
aussi on a la chance en france d'avoir
déjà pas mal d'infrastructures
existantes mais il faut préparer
d'autres et notamment les sites
yvelinois en terme de préparation
les chantiers ont commencé il ya les
municipalités ont commencé à investir
j'ai vu aussi qu'il y avait des salles
d'armes pour le judo qui était en train
d'être construite dans le département
donc oui là je pense que la perspective
et le les pointillés et la montée en
puissance vers les jo ont commencé moi
je dis non la course à 2024 n'a pas
commencé tout simplement parce que les
yeux de 2021 nous faut encore eu lieu
voilà en effet six l'avait légion et s
était s'était déjà déroulée cet été
bien sûr que les athlètes seraient
tournés vers 2024 pour l'instant habité
par elvire un suçon son programme bien
sûr tout à fait mais du coup dans ces
cas là ça veut dire que la préparation
pour 2024
elle a commencé à partir du moment où
paris a été
élue ville vit haute donc on n'est pas
du tout sur le même champ même débat là
pour moi donc voilà les athlètes sont
faux cul sur 2021 et focus avec quand
même une grosse épée de damoclès est un
gros doutes sur le déroulement des jo
parce que si on se projette simplement
dans ton juste six mois donc ça veut
dire six mois on sera au mois de mars
si la situation sanitaire ne s'est pas
grandement améliorée au niveau
international
je pense que ben les japonais ils vont
dire ben stop parce que je vais pas
faire venir des milliers de descendre
des dizaines ou des centaines de
milliers de personnes de partout dans le
monde pour venir contaminer tout le
monde sur nos petites îles donc donc il
ya un moment où en effet il est question
seront bonnes à se poser au mois de mars
avril comme comme un quand quand les
jeux ont été décalés l'année les l'année
dernière donc donc c'est vrai que pour
l'instant pour moi c'est faux cul sur
2021 et avec cette grosse incertitude de
pouvoir y participer ou pas stéphane qui
vous a convaincu pierre jan jan
je pense que c'est vrai il faut déjà
faire l'airé les jeux de 2021 ensuite
voir pour 2024 c'est vrai il ya toujours
cette épée damoclès qui nous emmerde
elle nous emmerdent même que face à voir
à quel point tout et tout et pas sur ces
on est dans l'incertitude totale jaune à
pourvoir s'est faite de différentes
ethnies quoi comment carton jaune pour o
bah oui quand même
jean après les cartons rouges qu'on voit
que ça genre qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je suis outré je voudrais moi langage
comme ça
non moi j'ai misé un terrain j'ai eu et
j'ai mis du temps à répondre est tout
simplement parce que c'est jouable pour
les deux c'est pour ça parce que pour
moi sportivement non
puisqu'il ya une amie legio pas eu lieu
donc sportivement pour moi ils font peu
pataud tourner vers 2024 mais par contre
au niveau préparation infrastructures et
tout ce qui tourne autour de l'événement
en france on y est déjà
ça c'est sûr c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
du thème qui peut répondre parce que
j'étais vraiment sur les deux cas de
figure donc voilà grégory non seulement
attendu j'avais aussi mis ainsi un petit
panneau rouge je suis plutôt d'accord
avec yann sur le côté voilà
l'incertitude c'est de savoir est ce que
ces jo 2021 vont se tenir pour l'instant
c'est ça qui est dans toutes les têtes
il ya ce collier de 19 à battre abattre
définitivement on l'espère et ensuite on
pourra se tourner voilà de la meilleure
des manières vers ces jo de paris alors
oui au niveau des villes c'est vrai on
est on est content on attend cet
événement avec la natation se mettre en
place un sou commence à se mettre en
place et il faut rappeler quand même
qu'il y avait 600 collectivités un qui
était candidate à la base pour obtenir
ces centres de préparation donc voilà
déjà c'est ça c'est acté c'est déjà une
sélection elles peuvent se préparer
tranquillement mais attendons au moins
que les jo-2020 tient ce puits se tenir
j' ai d'ailleurs en parlant de pour les
athlètes qui pourrait enchaîner des
périodes c'est vrai qu'il va y avoir un
gros chamboulements dans les
préparations parce que une olympiade
c'était quatre ans et entre le japon et
paris il n'y aura que trois ans c'est à
dire que l'année d'avant
normalement c'est à dire oui mais même
même si même si les jo de tokyo n'ont
pas lieu l'année écoulée elle sera quand
même passé et on sera en 2021 il faudra
déjà se tourner sur 2024 et le problème
c'est quand on sortait d'une préparation
enfin beaucoup d'athlètes qui sortait
d'une préparation olympique faisait un
break
ensuite prenez un exemple de teddy riner
par exemple qui qui pendant un an un an
et demi on ne voyait nulle part je vais
prendre l'exemple de florent manaudou
florent manaudou c'est pareil il a fait
un break après après rio est là en
faisant du handball et là il revient et
il revient grandement forme et c'est
vrai que balla le break ne sera pas
possible et il faudra tout de suite
repartir sur trois ans à nouveau de
préparation et ça va être alors florent
manaudou
la question ne se posera pas teddy riner
non plus parce que là ils sont trop trop
âgés mais des nouveaux
qui pourrait suivre ce même type de
programmation ne pourront pas le faire
et en effet on aura peut-être plus de
blessures pendant les trois années on
aura peut-être aussi une fatigue mentale
et morale qui sera plus importante et
les jo de 2024 pourrait être un petit
peu différent par rapport à tout ce
qu'on a vécu au bar à eau par aman alors
pour être tout à fait complet sur cette
thématique je rappelle que les ivy
n'auront plusieurs épreuves olympiques
il y aura le golf au golf national
l'équitation à versailles le vtt sur la
colline d'elancourt le cyclisme sur
piste au vélodrome nationale 2 à saint
quentin en yvelines et le bmx à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines on
passe maintenant à notre page des bas
[Musique]
dans cette page débat c'est votre
rubrique grégory nous l'avons baptisé
l'envolée de grégory de quoi allez vous
nous parler dans cette envolée ans je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui d'argent de
flouze money is money comme on dit alors
plutôt que de parler d'argent je vais
même parler de l'impact que peut avoir
l'argent sur le monde du sport le
dernier exemple en date forcément
mediapro ce groupe sino espagnols
détenteurs de 80% des droits télévisés
de la ligue 1 et la ligue 2 qui a poussé
le football français au bord de la
faillite
on revient sur les faits en 2018 la
ligue de football professionnel annonce
en grande pompe un contrat juteux est
les droits du football hexagonal vendu à
plus d'un milliard d'euros à canal+ free
est aussi principalement mediapro qui
s'est engagé à verser 814 millions
d'euros par saison entre 2020 et 2024
problème le 6 octobre dernier le groupe
n'a pas honoré sa tranche de 172
millions d'euros demandant un rampe un
report et voulant aussi renégocier à la
baisse sont contre arguant que la crise
sanitaire l'avait mise aussi en grande
difficulté alors le président de
mediapro dans une conférence de presse
on peut le dire un peu sketch
aujourd'hui cerao mais lourd s à
d'ailleurs repris vous avez apprécié
l'action espagnol j'espère a d'ailleurs
pris donc la parole je disais dans une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui
mercredi 21 octobre en disant que le
projet était maintenu que la situation
allait s'améliorer aussi demandé une
adaptation au vu de la crise sanitaire
alors de l'autre côté malheureusement
les clubs français se retrouvent en
grande difficulté l arrêt des
championnats et la perte de 300 millions
d'euros avait déjà été un sacré coup dur
mais il
ont tenu bon c'est clair ils ont tenu
bon et misait beaucoup sur ce nouveau
contrat pour des nouvelles entrées de
recettes et aussi pouvoir continuer
leurs projets d'investissement long et
coûteux
précisons qu'en moyenne les droits tv ça
représente environ 55% et des revenus
des clubs professionnels alors dans la
sphère média pro on a vu que ça a
conduit le football français au bord de
l'implosion la lfp elle va être obligée
d'emprunter 120 millions d'euros à une
banque anglo-saxonne taux d'intérêt à 5
5% pour sauver ces clubs
c'est une situation unique elle et j'en
terminerai par là sur mediapro qui
aurait pu sans doute être évités en 2018
la députée des yvelines
aurore bergé avait auditionné les
dirigeants du football français à ce
sujet elle les avait alertés notamment
sur le manque de garanties financières
apportées par le groupe sino espagnol
qui a d'ailleurs un précédent similaire
avec le championnat d'italie et à la des
plantes et du doigt aussi la trop grande
dépendance du football aux droits télé
auxquelles autour desquels le football a
construit son économie et vous vouliez
parler d'un autre exemple dans les
immigrés y fit mais alors là on ne parle
pas de droits télé mais plutôt de
sponsoring et de contrats juteux de
sponsoring dans le golfe 2018 décidément
c'est une hargne et nenê charnière pour
le football pour le golf aussi alors que
la france est encore dans l'engouement
de la ryder cup qui a été une grande
réussite et un sac et un sacré coup de
projecteur sur la discipline au golf
national le couperet tombe
il ne tombe fin octobre l'open de france
qui est le plus vieux tournoi du
continental perd son statut de rolex
séries ce qui regroupe par les
compétitions les plus prestigieuses du
circuit européen et chennai le
sponsor-titre depuis 2010 est de l'open
de france de golf a retiré ses billes
alors qu'il était engagé pour un minimum
de trois ans plus deux années en option
elle a raison à l'instar du groupe
mediapro de graves problèmes financiers
auxquels a dû faire face le groupe
chinois perte de statut donc perte aussi
de dotation qui est passé de 7 millions
à 3 millions d'euros perte aussi de
grands noms du golf qui avait pu se
bousculer sur les greens du golf
national notamment tommy fleetwood
vainqueur en 2010 est alexander noren
vainqueur en 2018 l'open a enfin été
déplacée à l'automne il s'est tenu
l'année dernière au mois d'octobre
c'était assez triste du vent de la pluie
on était à dix mille lieues des fastes
de la saison des saisons passées avec
le belge nicolas colsaerts alors pour
tout le respect que j'ai avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour le golf belge on
est loin de ce qui se faisait dans les
années précédentes il y avait notamment
aucun joueur mondial du top 50 mondial
présent sur place alors quand en 2018 on
rappelle qu'il y avait trois joueurs
dans le top 10 qui était présent à augst
nationale bref tout ça pour questionner
est ce que le sport pour briller pour
survivre aussi ne dépend t-il pas trop
des finances est un peu naïf peut-être
comme question mais je pense qu'on est
en droit de se la poser
pour précisions à nicolas colsaerts
n'avait plus gagné de tournoi depuis
sept ans un garde a fait alors la
question sur ce thème est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec grégory tout
simplement oui non oui oui oui tout on
est d'accord
yann pourquoi tout ça tellement bien de
gagner c'est plus facile par rapport aux
plus de touche quand on est à la maison
tout simplement sans argent on ne fait
absolument rien mais donc c'est le nerf
de la guerre on est bien d'accord mais
c'est pas que dans le sport c'est dans
tous les domaines vous vous êtes dans la
recherche si vous n'avez pas d'argent
vous ne pouvez pas travailler quand vous
êtes au travail quand vous voulez
organiser une événement si on vous dit
le budget c'est rien avec lui rien vous
ne vous fait rien voilà faux pas on
n'est pas des magiciens malheureusement
donc donc de toutes façons et bien sûr
que en effet l'argent prend une place
très importante dans tous les domaines
maintenant c'est la dépendance bien sûr
mais attendez vous prenez je prends des
tentes du cyclisme une équipe comme la
sky à l'époque avec le plus gros budget
de
du peloton du peloton pro ils ont gagné
x fois le tour de france je crois que
c'est fin voilà plusieurs fois le tour
de france on se de mémoire mais ils ont
remporté tous les tous les grands tours
avec plus ou moins de réussite dans
certains mais mais voilà à partir du
moment où on a l'argent on est capable
par exemple également alors le psg pour
l'instant ils ont atteint en effet la
finale de la ligue des champions ils
n'ont pas encore gagné mais ça viendra
ça viendra bien sûr manchester city l'a
fait ils ont pris aussi énormément de
temps pour pouvoir pour pouvoir gagner
la ligue des champions et finalement
chelsea manchester city mais sinon c'est
celle ci qui voit là on a des exemples
voilà on va d exemple partout et dans la
formule 1 c'est pareil quand vous allez
plus d'argent vous arrivez à voir les
bateaux parce que bientôt on va parler
du du vendée globe et donc les bateaux
c'est pareil quand vous avez les
meilleurs bateaux prochain quand vous
avez les meilleurs bateaux et bien en
effet vous allez plus vite donc oui bien
sûr que l'argent est le moteur et moteur
dans le sport et dans tout et dans tous
les domaines pierre vous donnerez
apparaît ensuite il faut peut-être faire
la distinction entre le sport
professionnel et sport amateur
là c'est le seul le bémol que je que
j'apporterai à la présentation de
grégory avec peut-être malgré tout dans
les années depuis des quais depuis
quelques années un nivellement par le
haut avec une extrême dépendance du
sport professionnel de des droits télé
notamment et donc et donc des budgets de
sponsoring des partenaires et qui
commence à qui comment ça rejaillira
descendre un petit peu dans les dents
les équipes de sport amateur
je pense aux chevauchements soit rugby
aussi où certains certains joueurs et
par exemple des emplois qui leur sont
trouvés par les clubs cc c'est quand
même déjà déjà commencé à parler un
petit peu de finances
et deuxième chose qui m'étonne
ce qui m'étonne là-dedans paradoxalement
dans le milieu du sport c'est qu'on a on
a une différence entre
entre la parole le contrat et la réalité
grégory rappeler les déboires les
atermoiements de v des accrocs c'est
quand même incroyable que dans le sport
on ne soit pas capable
alors effectivement il ya des gros gros
enjeu mais qu'on ne soit pas capable de
respecter une parole donnée et là je
pense qu'on a on a dérapé en vers le
justement le la toute puissance des
finances dans le sport est justement on
en voit déjà les premières conséquences
dommageables
s'il faut ajouter sur mediapro c'est
peut-être le football français je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas dans les petits
papiers dans les instances du football
français mais a été aveuglé peut-être
par le juteux contrat à plus d'un
milliard d'euros de la ligue 1 de droits
télé c'est plus par exemple que si
j'avais en série a c'est en série a sur
le championnat italien c'est plus ces
voix là c'est du jamais vu la vie est
quand même plus intéressant je n'ai pas
forcément mais on pourra dans une autre
émission je suis pas d'accord mais
peut-être fait que les dirigeants du
football français ont été aveuglés par
un juteux contrat et non pas demandé ils
n'ont pas demandé de garanties
financières ça c'est important de le
préciser
mediapro n'a apporté aucune garantie
financière avant de verser ces tranches
de droits télé donc il ya peut-être
aussi eu des erreurs du côté des
instances du far west c'est une habitude
un canal pareil n'avait pas apporté de
garanties financières ou bine sport
également là pour le coup après pour
terminer je voudrais pas c'est que ces
entreprises vivent aussi un contexte qui
n'a jamais eu précédent et on est seul
argument juste trop de médias pont et
voilà et voilà les ai en effet il ya un
moment où quand on diffuse pas de match
comment est ce que vous voulez que moi
j'ai les rentrées d'argent puisque vous
n'avez pas fait de vous n'est pas de
produit le produit ce que moi je dois
vendre vous moi je vende des matchs que
vous que vos clubs doivent
doivent comment doivent faire là les
matchs n'ont pas pu être félé fin de
championnat n'ont pas eu lieu
comment est ce que vous voulez que moi
je puisse récupérer l'argent auprès
d'annonceurs pour vous leur reverser
derrière il ya un moment où c'est la
réalité du terrain et c'est la même
chose qu'aujourd'hui un restaurateur
demande à l'état français
c'est de dire diminuées nous nos charges
parce que aujourd'hui on peut pas
recevoir no comment les clientes dans
les conditions dans les conditions
habituelles
donc il ya un moment où un effet on peut
pas payer la même chose que ce que l'on
devait habituellement donc en pratique
ça aurait pu être évitée tout à l'heure
je vais encore parler de football
italien j'en profite dans cette émission
d'avoir cette tribune à vienne lover il
ya eu un précédent de mediapro avec eux
le championnat d'italie ce t il ya deux
ans tout était signé et au moment où la
ligue de football italienne a demandé à
les gars proa lega pro à mediapro
d'apporter les garanties financières le
groupe sino espagnol n'a pas été capable
de les apporter
et du coup à deux jours du début du
championnat on s'est retrouvé dans une
situation où les contrats ont été
rompues et la ligue de foot britten a dû
trouver en urgence de nouveau diffuseur
donc il y avait quand même des
précédents qui pouvaient alerté le
football français et aurore bergé qu'ont
entendu effectivement députés celle ci
avait notamment mené une enquête
là-dessus genre oui alors moi je voulais
je voulais revenir quand même à la base
là on disait le sport des vannes des
piles de l'argent et non je te le mile
end départ je rajouterais parce que je
parle les halles je prends l'exemple du
rugby c'est que c'est les sponsors qu'il
faut les calendriers à savoir que moi
quand j'étais jeune
le rugby qu'à y avait les mains du
tournoi des six nations
comment il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
vous étiez jeune oui et il ya très peu
de temps et a très très peu de temps non
mes cahiers de base du taux longs et
syna sûr il n'y avait pas de jouer un
championnat en france
aujourd'hui vous avez des matches de
l'équipe nationale française qui se
déroule en plein milieu au même moment
que les matchs de national 2 fédéral en
phrases illégalement 14
même le top 14 est peut-être 14 jours
pendant la coupe du monde c'est son
palais les fédérations qui décident de
des calendriers sportifs mais c'est bien
les partenaires les diffuseurs qui
disent bon là nous on veut que ce match
là ils soient du fise est tel jour à
telle heure
et donc on est plus que des pandas mais
on est on est accroché et hu qui dirige
ce qui décide c'est l'allemagne qui
dirige le monde
qu'est ce que vous en pensez y vous
stéphane qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je suis d'accord avec jean
j'aurais juste une question à poser à
grégory il paraîtrait aussi que canal +
songerait à re négocier aussi puisque
maudire pro fait pareil je sais pas s'il
a des impôts
effectivement ou et maxime saada
directeur général d or il ne travaille
pas chez média 6 mai maxime saada
directeur général de canal+ sa demande
est effectivement est la lfp de traiter
tous les diffuseurs à la même enseigne
c'est à dire que si la lfp aujourd'hui
accepte de renégocier à la baisse le
contrat avec mediapro il en va de même
aussi pour canal c'est en tout cas
l'égalité de traitement cadeaux demandé
canal j'ajouterai juste que la lfp
assigné en justice au tribunal de
commerce
mediapro pour obliger l'investisseur
principal actionnaire principal de
mediapro qui est le un groupe chinois
dont le nom m'échappe je vais je vais
regarder ça mais a payé cette tranche de
droite et des 172 millions d'euros
pierre chevalier on a parlé également de
l'exemple dash est né pour l'open de
france de golf
finalement ce sponsor a peut-être pas
tué mais en tout cas fortement dégradée
ce tournoi qui est l'un des plus vieux
tournoi c'est plus frontier normand
européen on repère mais ils me voient un
tournoi la vie d'un tournoi peut
basculer dans un sens comme dans un
autre pour par rapport à sponsors il l'a
très certainement blessé peut-être pas
encore t'es pas encore mortellement mais
c'est où on ajoute à ça un contexte au
moment où à chênée retire ses billes
un an et demi un an et demi trop tôt par
rapport à la parole donnée au contrat de
deux années en option en plus en plus en
plus on est dans une période où
houleux on est à une charnière pour
l'open de france qui s'était installée
depuis juste deux trois années dans
parmi les rolex séries les plus belles
et plus beau plateau du tour européen
juste après aussi la la ryder cup qui
s'est déroulée avec le succès qu'on
connaît
et là c'est effectivement pour le golf
une dépendance sur la partie prize money
c'est à dire sur la partie rétribution
du du top 10 top 20 top 30 et qui fait
venir les meilleurs joueurs de la
planète qui sinon s'ils n'ont pas 7,7
cet attrait très financier parce qu'il
faut en parler comme ça vont jouer les
tournois américains et les tournois du
tour américain qui se déroule
généralement en même temps là c'est la
même chose c'est aussi un problème de
calendrier télescopage de deux
compétitions
donc oui quand à chênée a retiré ses dix
alors effectivement raison invoquée la
difficulté de l'avionneur de l'avionneur
chinois pour pouvoir honorer faute de
trésorerie ses obligations mais au
moment où il l'a fait ça a donné un coup
que l'on espère pas fatal pour l'open de
france à guillon c'est pour raisons
économiques car mediapro par rapport au
corps vidé ce groupe h est né également
par rapport à des soucis financiers
d'entreprises alors on continue ceux ci
ont parlé sport part du golfe et
justement c'est un concept novateur en
europe
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a inauguré ce mercredi 14
octobre un stade d'entraînement de haute
performance à destination des futures
pépites ceux du golf français et d un
professionnel un outil pour leur
permettre de performer on écoute pascal
grizot le futur président de la
fédération française de golf c'est
surtout c'est une zone qui est d'abord
une zone qui a été étudié spécialement
pour la haute performance c'est à dire
rencontrer les conditions que nos
athlètes vont rencontrer lorsqu'il joue
des compétitions sur les plus beaux et
plus difficile parcours du
et cette zone a repris les noa tête vont
pouvoir se retrouver dans les conditions
de ses plus grands tournois
pierre vous l'avez vu ce nouveau style
de golf
je les pages les vues en travaux je n'ai
pas vu encore inauguré je n'ai pas pu je
n'ai pas pu l'essayer grands champions
de beule que je suis mais mais c'est une
c'est une très très belle avancée pour
le le sport professionnel est justement
pour nos futurs pouces je reprendrai le
terme que pascal grizot à utiliser sur
votre antenne quand vous l'avais
interviewé en disant que désormais les
golfeurs français ont une formule 1 et
que maintenant il faut il faut bien bien
former les champions et les conducteurs
de demain et donc les champions de golf
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir performer et
se frotter aux plus grands grâce à cet
outil là ils vont pouvoir s'entraîner
justement progressé de manière plus
rapide
justement on va l'écouter peut-être
pascal grizot justement il dit
exactement ce que vous venez de dire
mais à sa façon
on va l'écouter c'est pas parce qu'on a
les meilleures infrastructures que on a
forcément des champions si je vous mets
dans la dans une formule 1 je suis pas
certain que vous soyez capable de
rivaliser avec hamilton donc il nous
faut de très belles formules 1 et on
vient d'en livrer une mais il nous faut
maintenant les pilotes qui vont pouvoir
être capable de conduire cette formule 1
très bonne mémoire un pierre chevallier
alors je simple si je me suis les
recteurs de tv 78 je vois ça se passe à
côté dans les visions et vous est le
chouchou d y vivre
alors le stade de performance c'est la
première pierre d'un projet a beaucoup
plus large à côté du practice de l'oise
les un dortoir pouvant accueillir 24
sportif et si staff sera construit dans
le lait à prochains mois un plateau
performance sera également développée à
destination des jeunes avec une école de
la préparation physique et du travail
technique avec des modélisations du
swing objectif mettre la nouvelle
génération dans les meilleures
conditions la question sur ce thème
cet équipement va-t-il créer des
champions oui ou non vous avez déjà
commencé à répondre à la question
pierre oui oui j'en également pour vous
aussi stéphane peut-être
grégory qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais moi ce que je voudrais dire après
je laisserai la parole je suis pas un
grand grand spécialiste de golf donc je
vais pas pouvoir apporter énormément de
choses à ce débat moi ce que je
souhaitais dire c'est que on est aussi
content quand même dans les yvelines
on à clairefontaine pour le football
maintenant on aura peut-être le
clairefontaine du golfe on et voilà sur
un territoire former les futures pépites
ya le vélodrome nationale aussi bien sûr
pardon pardon via nous on n'y échappe
mais on est sur un territoire des
yvelines voilà qui forme les futurs
champions et ça je pense qu'on peut que
se réjouir dans cette émission et qui
est consacré à l'actualité du sport
hypnose disponibles il ya yann c'est
difficile de réussir
oui enfin en effet quand on me pose la
question si ce type de 2,2 d'équipement
va former des nouveaux champions
bien sûr je vais prendre l'exemple du
vélodrome nationale avant on n'avait
aucun pistard dans les yvelines et grâce
au vélodrome nationale eh bien on a un
jeune on a un jeune du du du coin qui a
été qui a pu participer aux championnats
de france je crois qu'il a dû ramener en
plus médaille de médailles et dès qu'il
est évident et de chats pl troyes
s'était jamais arrivé dans le cyclisme
auparavant tout simplement parce qu'on
n'avait pas de on n'avait pas de
sculptures attiré par le national je
pars fait de l'auto reste elle sort
était un vélodrome
quel qu'il soit de toute façon ça aurait
donné l'envi à des personnes proches
quand vous avez la meilleure structure
nationale proche de chez vous bien sûr
que c'est un aspirateur qui est encore
plus important
donc là le golf le golf qui en plus est
depuis une grosse dizaine d'années est
un sport qui se démocratise ce n'est
plus un sport de riches pratiqué par les
riches faux pas c'est un sport qui est
devenu accessible à beaucoup et bien si
en plus grâce à ça et bien oui grâce à 7
vous avez le meilleur outil dans la
région parce que faut pas croire ça va
pas drainé que les gens de saint quentin
en yvelines
là vous allez avoir des plans qui vont
venir de bien plus loin le vélodrome
nationale moi j'ai des copains qui
viennent m'a déjà déconnectés de
normandie 2 qui n 2 mo pour pouvoir
s'entraîner donc là il va y avoir des
gens qui vont se déplacer pour pouvoir
utiliser dessous cette structure par
contre j'ai cru dans votre reportage que
c'était destiné que aux élites mais
finalement
c'est plutôt pour les élites c'est à
elle plutôt pour les hélices donc les
professionnels
il est également les jeunes qui ont
entre 10 et 18 ans d'accord ils partent
généralement avec johnny à l'étranger
oui mais peut-être que aussi ce type de
structure sera qu'on arrivera à les
garder à les conserver
donc c'est novateur en europe 1 ce
samedi et donc du coup peut-être en plus
en plus de très bons français de très
bons jeunes français on aura peut-être
de très beaux jeunes européens qui
viendront ça prendra du temps ça va pas
se faire en deux ans c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui sera plus pour
probable dans une dizaine d'années quand
ben les les entraîneurs qui seront ici
auront montré que justement il s'agit
d'utiliser cet outil est que grâce à
l'outil on peut avoir des performances
et voilà ça prendra quelques années mais
il ya deux forces est fort probable que
ce soit même un outil européen de de
formation et pas de détection par bien
de deux formations pour pouvoir obtenir
des des bons golfeurs
alors en plus on a déjà la chance en
europe de toutes façons d'avoir de très
bons golfeurs puisque la ryder cup on la
gagne régulièrement
voilà j'ai pas les j'ai pas lu ici en
tout cas là mais elle est donc on arrive
à gagner la ryder cup donc à partir de
ce moment là bas si en plus on peut
former des jeunes main tendue est il si
c'est à côté de chez nous battons pierre
chevallier
on avait une équation à trois inconnues
au départ pour le golf professionnel et
notamment pour nos jeunes pousses la
première yann l'a rappelé et le
développement du golf depuis quelques
années où on a une activité qui est en
plein essor parce que c'est une activité
verte c'est une activité qui peut se
pratiquer à plusieurs et qui peut se
pratiquer à c'est assez tard dans la vie
la deuxième c'est que on a une grosse
progression post co vide le golf a été
la première activité qui a pu qui a pu
reprendre le 11 mai après le confinement
justement par ces par ces garanties de
pouvoir avoir la distanciation dieu sait
que au golf généralement même même en
partie iii ou ne fait pas tout le temps
les le parcours côte à côte on va un
petit peu dans les bois dans les
obstacles à mame cheikh mbaye habitant
également ou donc ça c'est garanti
la troisième est inconnu au départ c'est
qu'il y avait quand même déjà quelques
surface d'entraînement existantes
je pense au golf de mionnay qui est
qu'ils avaient avec le golflower il une
structure d'entraînement absolument
unique qui est toujours la seule en
france a maintenant la deuxième avec
après le les travaux du golf national
les équipes boys d'ailleurs s'y
enchaîner s'y entraîner amyot nez on a
aussi à terre blanche aussi avec avec
une world paint your view ou des joueurs
professionnels français et européens
venaient s'entraîner donc là je pense
que c'est là aussi une après cette
équation une solution de cohérence comme
le rappelait gregorio si on à
clairefontaine pour le foot on à
marcoussis pour le rugby est désormais
le golf national devait se doter de ce
type de structure certes au plus tôt
pour les bons joueurs et pour l'élite
mais vu le positionnement et que c'est
le golf de la fédération est là et le et
l'accessibilité de ceux-ci plein ça va
profiter à tous les joueurs français
mais d'abord d'abord au futur aux
futures grandes et aux futurs grands
joueurs du circuit européen en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on va ce côté grégory
justement les français ne brille pas
forcément on peut le dire sur le circuit
n'ont pas forcément même si mickaël il
ya peut-être un petit rayon de soleil je
vais vous expliquer alors il faut aller
jusqu'à la 37e place un mondial pour
trouver le premier français c'est victor
perez qui a fait tout de même une belle
progression au mois d'octobre là lui qui
était au début du mois d'octobre 53e
mais c'est le seul français présent dans
le top 100 michael lorenzo-vera vient
d'être éjecté des 100 premiers joueurs
lors de la dernière mise à jour du
classement il est désormais 103e suivent
ensuite romain langage que son neuvième
benjamin hebert qui est lui 122e paul
bourgeon 179e et après il faut aller au
delà de la 200e place pour trouver des
joueurs français citons par exemple
alexander levy 1 qui lui hier à une 450e
place mondiale le petit rayon de soleil
c'est victor dubuisson 303e mondial
certes m et qui enregistre une belle
progression lui qui n'avait pas joué
pendant de longs mois et sur les six
tournois qu'il a joués cette année il a
terminé à deux reprises dans le top 10
une neuvième place par exemple lors du
dernier scottish open et victor
dubuisson le rappelle qu'on a envie de
voir revenir qui a été jusqu'à 15e
mondial c'est le meilleur classement
dans l'histoire pour un golfeur français
genre très rapide
en quelques secondes est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec grégory il faut
l'italien lui oui et pas par nous tous
il est bien trop petit merci alors c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de la légende du golf tiger
woods quand vous avez un but véritable
dans la vie travailler dur mais plus une
option à c'est une nécessité
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78 carats corps
[Musique]